This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Do you remember airplane travel? Backing into a tin can with 200 other people all breathing each other's air? Well, these days most of us are still avoiding planes. But in the before times, when we boarded a flight, we all received the same familiar set of instructions. set of instructions. If you've ever flown on a plane, you've been directed to study the plane's safety briefing card. Every passenger plane, commercial or private, has to have safety cards on board.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。还记得坐飞机旅行吗？和另外 200 人一起挤进一个锡罐头里，呼吸着彼此呼出的空气？好吧，如今我们大多数人仍然在避免坐飞机。但在疫情爆发前的那些日子里，当我们登上一架航班时，我们都会收到同样一组熟悉的指令。如果你曾坐过飞机，你一定被指引过去研究飞机上的安全须知卡。每一架客机，无论是商业客机还是私人飞机，都必须在机上配备安全卡。
And if you're like most people, you probably never bothered to examine it too closely. That is, if you've even looked at it at all. I always look at these things. As soon as I sit down on a plane, I pull out the safety card. Today, I'm gonna be talking with producer Mo LeBorn about why safety cards might be worth a closer look. Hi, Roman.
如果你和大多数人一样，你可能从没费心去仔细查看它。也就是说，如果你甚至看都没看过的话。我总是看这些东西。一登上飞机坐下，我就会把安全卡抽出来。今天，我将与制作人莫·勒博恩（Mo LeBorn）一起探讨为什么安全卡可能值得我们仔细瞧瞧。嗨，罗曼。
Hi, Mo. So you're saying you always pull out the safety card? Yeah, I mean, what can I say? I just love airplane safety cards. Honestly, I think I love them a little bit too much. I don't just look at them. I collect them. I've been collecting for about 10 years. 10 years.
嗨，莫。所以你是说你总是会把安全卡抽出来？对啊，我的意思是，我能说什么呢？我就是喜欢飞机安全卡。老实说，我觉得我有点太喜欢它们了。我可不只是看看而已。我还收集它们。我已经收集大约 10 年了。10 年。
So when you say collect them, what do you mean? Well, whenever I fly on the plane, I just snag the card and I put it in my backpack. So you just take them? Is that allowed? I actually don't. Is that a problem? It's a a question because it's technically not allowed, but I just have such a strong clopdomania for this one object today in my collection.
所以当你说收集它们时，是什么意思？嗯，每当我坐飞机时，我就会顺走安全卡，然后把它塞进我的背包里。所以你直接拿走它们？这被允许吗？其实我不——这有什么问题吗？这是一个好问题，因为从技术上讲这是不允许的，但我对这单一物件有着极其强烈的窃取癖，目前在我的收藏中。
I have about 300. That's cool. So why do you have 300 safety cards? I think it's that for me, I fell in love with them because they're like safety-themed comic strips. Like, outfits of the women are stuck in the 1960s. There are little girls wearing Mary Jane shoes and Bobby socks. And it's just so, the way they look is so fascinating to me.
我有大约 300 张。太酷了。那你为什么会有 300 张安全卡呢？我想对我而言，我爱上它们是因为它们就像是安全主题的连环画。比如，女人们的穿着还停留在 20 世纪 60 年代。有小女孩穿着玛丽珍鞋和白短袜。它们的视觉风格让我觉得太迷人了。
But more than that, like I am especially fascinated with the way that they depict a plane crash. Like it's this alternate version of events where there's no blood, there's no wreckage from the crash. Nobody's distressed, and their hair doesn't even get messed up. Like it's so obviously the opposite of what an actual plane crash would look like. Absolutely. When I see these cards, I always think of the movie Fight Club,
但不仅如此，比如我对它们描绘飞机坠毁的方式尤其着迷。这就像是一个事件的平行版本，里面没有血迹，没有飞机残骸。没有人惊慌失措，他们的头发甚至连乱都没乱。这显然与真实空难发生时的样子截然相反。绝对是这样。当我看到这些卡片时，我总是会想起电影《搏击俱乐部》，
where Brad Pitt's character is just, it's outright mocks the way that people look on these cards. Emergency water landing 600 miles an hour. Blank faces, calm as Hindu cows. The illusion of safety. And then like later on, you see Ed Norton and Brad Pitt replace the normal safety cards with cards where everyone is like freaked out and panicking. Yeah, and I think that the Fight Club scene gets at something about how most of us think
布拉德·皮特（Brad Pitt）扮演的角色在里面直接嘲讽了人们在这些卡片上的样子。水上紧急迫降，时速 600 英里。面无表情，平静得像印度神牛。虚假的安全感。然后过了一会儿，你会看到爱德华·诺顿（Ed Norton）和布拉德·皮特把正常的安全卡换成了那种每个人都吓坏了、惊慌失措的卡片。是的，我觉得《搏击俱乐部》的那个场景触及了我们大多数人的一种想法，
the cards aren't actually necessary. Like at some gut level, we just assume that if we're in a crash, everyone's gonna die. But then after I began collecting them, I started looking into the history of these cards and where they come from. And basically, what I learned is that we have that all wrong. Safety cards work. Really? I would not have thought that.
那就是这些卡片其实并没有什么必要。在某种直觉层面，我们只是假设如果我们遭遇坠机，每个人都会死。但后来自我开始收集它们之后，我开始研究这些卡片的历史以及它们的由来。基本上，我了解到的是我们的想法完全错了。安全卡是有用的。真的吗？我可不会这么想。
Yeah, reading a safety card can save your life. But also, it turns out that safety cards have played a central role in our evolving understanding of how to survive a plane crash. Alright, we'll tell me more. What is it that we owe to the safety card? Well, to answer that, first, we have to go back a ways. To a time when safety cards were pretty much useless. In fact, they weren't even really about safety.
对，阅读安全卡可以救你的命。而且事实证明，在我们需要不断提升如何从空难中生还的理解方面，安全卡一直发挥着核心作用。好吧，多跟我讲讲。我们究竟应该感谢安全卡什么？嗯，要回答这个问题，我们首先得回溯到过去。回到安全卡基本上毫无用处的时代。事实上，它们甚至跟安全没多大关系。
Because in the early days of passenger airplane travel in the 1930s, there was no regulation at all about what should go in the cards. And in the beginning, airlines had to convince people to get on planes because people were scared to fly. So the early cards were all about soothing passengers, telling them on the idea that air travel was safe and glamorous. And they were essentially just miniature versions of those travel postcards, like little advertisements for the airlines. So here, let me show you a really early card. This one was made by Imperial Airways in the 1930s. Oh, okay, this one says Imperial Airways comfort and convenience, and there's little cherubs
因为在 20 世纪 30 年代乘客飞机旅行的早期，对于卡片上应该写些什么没有任何规定。起初，航空公司必须说服人们登机，因为人们害怕飞行。所以早期的卡片全是关于安慰乘客的，向他们灌输航空旅行既安全又迷人的观念。它们本质上只是旅游明信片的微缩版，就像是航空公司的微型广告。所以来，我给你看一张非常早期的卡片。这张是帝国航空公司（Imperial Airways）在 30 年代制作的。哦，好的，这张上面写着“帝国航空公司，舒适与便利”，还有几个小天使
carrying a fat, fancy man in the hammock. That's lovely. That is not the depiction of air travel in any way, shape or form. No, it's a fantasy. And if you open it up, all of the instructions pretty much are all text. Okay, so here's some of this. Okay. To inflate the belt, hold the air bottle, which you can feel inside the belt in the left hand and press lever B upwards with the right hand. That is not very clear. Do you know what that means? No, I really don't. And sadly, this card is characteristic of the whole first wave of safety card design
抬着一个胖乎乎、穿戴讲究的男人在吊床里。这太可爱了。这在任何方面、任何形状或形式上都不像是航空旅行的写照。不，这纯粹是幻想。如果你把它打开，所有的说明基本上全都是文字。好吧，这里有一些这样的内容。好的。要给救生衣充气，请用左手握住位于救生衣内部的气瓶，然后用右手将 B 杠杆向上推。这写得一点都不清楚。你知道那是什么意思吗？不，我真的不知道。可悲的是，这张卡片正是整个 30 和 40 年代
throughout the 30s and 40s. And to be fair, by the mid 60s, things that improved a bit. You start to see these things called fleet cards, which were almost like spiral bound booklets that contained the safety instructions for multiple plane models in multiple languages. But that often just made it harder to find the correct safety information because there were so many pages to flip through. So how did we get from that to the kinds of cards that we're familiar with today? Well, things really started to change in the late 1960s when airlines started noticing a troubling pattern when it came to crashes.
第一波安全卡设计特征的缩写。公平地说，到了 60 年代中期，情况确实有所改善。你开始看到一种叫做机队卡（fleet card）的东西，它几乎就像是线装小册子，包含了多种语言的多种飞机型号的安全须知。但这往往只会让人更难找到正确的安全信息，因为有太多页需要翻阅。那么，我们是怎么从那种卡片演变成今天我们熟悉的这种卡片的呢？事情在 20 世纪 60 年代末真正开始改变，当时航空公司开始注意到一个关于坠机的令人不安的规律。
Impact survival was possible, but not escape. Dan Johnson is a psychologist who specializes in airplane safety. And he says that in the 50s and 60s, air travel was growing increasingly safe. Plains crashed less often. And when they did crash, thanks to design improvements, those crashes were less fatal, all of which should have added up to more survivors. But unfortunately, those survivors were not always getting out of the airplane time to survive. And I have to say, this is the part of the story that made me throw out everything I
撞击后的生还有可能是存在的，但逃生却很难。丹·约翰逊（Dan Johnson）是一位专注于飞机安全的心理学家。他说，在 50 和 60 年代，航空旅行变得越来越安全。飞机坠毁的频率降低了。而当它们确实坠毁时，由于设计上的改进，这些坠机事件的致命性也降低了，所有这些本该意味着会有更多的幸存者。但不幸的是，这些幸存者并不总能在飞机上及时逃生。我必须得说，故事的这一部分让我抛弃了所有
had assumed about airplane safety. Because it turns out that if you're in a serious crash, it's not the impact that kills you. There's very few accidents that kill everyone aboard. Instead, what kills you is what happens next. It's the smoke and fire inside the cabin after the crash. So the key to surviving is getting out of the plane as fast as possible. Huh. I guess I never thought about it that way before, that the important thing is just exiting the plane. Yeah, and this is the realization
原本对飞机安全的假设。因为事实证明，如果你遭遇了一场严重的坠机，真正夺去你性命的并不是撞击。很少有事故会夺走机上所有人的生命。相反，夺走你性命的是接下来发生的事情。是撞击后客舱内的浓烟和烈火。所以生还的关键是以尽可能快的速度逃离飞机。哈。我猜我以前从来没从这个角度想过，原来最重要的是离开飞机。是的，这就是
accident investigators had in the 1960s. They calculated that in your average crash, people had about 90 seconds to get out of the plane before it became, quote, unquote, unservivable. But again and again, they found that passengers weren't making it out in time. In one accident, quote unquote, unsurvivable. But again and again, they found that passengers weren't making it out in time. In one accident, for example, there were 101 passengers aboard
事故调查人员在 20 世纪 60 年代意识到的事情。他们计算得出，在一般的坠机事故中，人们大约有 90 秒的时间逃离飞机，否则飞机就会变得“毫无生还可能”。但他们一次又一次地发现，乘客并没有及时逃生。例如，在一次事故中，有 101 名乘客登机，
four survivors. And the people who were killed were not killed as a result of the impact, but because they couldn't get out to the door. That's so dreadful. It's nightmare fuel. And it was a nightmare for the airline industry too, which is why, in 1968, Douglas aircraft decided to improve their safety record by hiring Dan, along
只有 4 名幸存者。遇难的人并不是因为撞击而丧生，而是因为他们无法逃到舱门外。这太可怕了。简直是噩梦般的场景。对航空业来说这也是一场噩梦，正因如此，在 1968 年，道格拉斯飞机公司（Douglas aircraft）决定通过聘请丹来改善他们的安全记录，
with another guy named Bo Altman. I had never been on an airplane in my life. That's Bo. Like Dan, he's also a psychologist who specializes in airplane safety. But back when he was first hired at Douglas, he says he didn't know the first thing about air travel. Well, I still like, but I'd never been on one of those great big monster airplanes. So the first time he entered a proper passenger plane was to give it a safety inspection. And my first inclination was when I entered the back door of the airplane was where are the exits.
还有另一个人叫博·奥尔特曼（Bo Altman）。我这辈子从来没坐过飞机。那是博。和丹一样，他也是一位专注于飞机安全的心理学家。但当初刚被道格拉斯聘用时，他说自己对航空旅行一无所知。嗯，我还是挺——但我从来没坐过那些巨大无比的飞机。所以他第一次走进一架真正的客机是为了进行安全检查。我走入飞机后门时的第一直觉就是：紧急出口在哪里？
And I could not see any exits. I could only see the door which I came through. And I said, well, how does a passenger know where to go in the event of an emergency? So he started walking through the airplane and he noticed all the doors were covered with curtains. And why were they covered? Was it just for aesthetics? Oh yeah, they didn't want anybody to know that there was a possibility of an emergency exit there. They didn't want to talk about safety at all. And then he took a look at their safety cards. So I looked at and I said this is is terrible. Is it all in three languages? And no pictures or nothing, it was just read it and weep. And I said, we've got a problem here.
我根本看不到任何出口。我只能看到我进来的那扇门。我说，那么在紧急情况下，乘客怎么知道该往哪走呢？于是他开始在飞机里走动，注意到所有的门都被窗帘盖住了。为什么它们被盖住呢？难道只是为了美观？哦，对，他们不想让任何人知道那里可能存在紧急出口。他们根本不想谈论安全。然后他看了看他们的安全卡。所以我看了一眼，心想这太糟糕了。这全是用三种语言写的吗？
We need to teach passengers how to get out of that airplane in a hurry. So Bowen Dan decided to fail in a company together to improve airline safety procedures. They called it the interaction research corporation, and their specialty was running tests in mock cabins full of research participants. So Dan and I did tons of work on how do we get 450 people aboard that airplane off everybody off, including the crew in 98 seconds. And they would start by making each test as realistic as possible. They always made sure that there were X amount of people under the age of 6 and so many people over the age of 70. And they have only been given their passenger briefing that it would be on a regular airplane.
一张图片都没有，简直就是让人看了想哭。我说，我们这里有个大问题。我们需要教乘客如何在紧急情况下逃出那架飞机。于是博和丹决定成立一家公司来共同改善航空公司的安全程序。他们将其命名为互动研究公司（Interaction Research Corporation），他们的专长是在挤满研究参与者的模拟客舱中进行测试。所以丹和我做了大量的工作：我们如何让 450 个人在 98 秒内全部撤离飞机，把包括机组人员在内的所有人全部撤离？他们通常会通过让每次测试尽可能逼真来开始。他们总是确保有 X 数量的 6 岁以下儿童和 Y 数量的 70 岁以上老人。并且只给他们提供常规飞机上的那种乘客须知。
And then they would just toss a smoke bomb into the fake plane cabin. Then, boom, lights go off. Emergency, emergency evacuate, evacuate. Release your seatbelt, release your seatbelt. Get up, get up, get up, move, move, move. Get to the exit. And then when they got to the exit, they would be 15 feet above the ground and they had the jump into an inflatable slide in the dark and they'd never done it before. And trying to get everyone moving as fast as possible, these experiments could actually get dangerous. I have no doubt. Yeah, they got a lot of him. We tried to provide as much realism as we could
然后他们会在模拟飞机客舱里扔进一颗烟雾弹。接着，轰的一声，灯光熄灭。紧急情况，紧急情况，疏散，疏散！解开你的安全带，解开你的安全带！站起来，站起来，站起来，移动，移动，移动！去出口！然后当他们到达出口时，他们会离地面 15 英尺高，他们必须在黑暗中跳进一个充气滑梯，而他们以前从来没有这样做过。为了让每个人都尽可能快地动起来，这些实验实际上会变得很危险。毫无疑问。是的，他们遇到了很多情况。我们试图在不伤害人们的前提下
without hurting people. We still hurt a lot of people. Early. Yeah, a lot of people got hurt jumping out of the slides. But nevertheless, we did it. It was for the greater good. Yes, yes. And their tests were an information gold mine. All the participants would be wearing numbered vests
提供尽可能多的真实感。我们还是伤了很多人。早期的时候。是的，很多人在从滑梯上跳下来时受伤了。不过尽管如此，我们还是做到了。这是为了更伟大的事业。是的，是的。他们的测试简直就是信息金矿。所有的参与者都穿着印有数字的背心，
indicating their seat number, their age, their gender. And Bowen Dan would be filming the whole thing to see who went where and who did what? I figured that I had looked at about 10,000 people over 10 years looking at whether they sat down at the door still, how long they waited until they followed the behavior of the passenger in front. So, for example, with that thing Dan just mentioned, whenever people sat down at the door before going down the slide, they found that it took an extra half second per person. And if you've got maybe 100 passengers going out of a door, then that's 40 or 50 seconds.
标明他们的座位号、年龄、性别。博和丹会把整个过程拍摄下来，看看谁去了哪里，谁做了什么。我算过，在 10 年里我大约观察了 10,000 个人，看他们是否会在舱门前坐下来，看他们等待多久才会跟随前方乘客的行为。所以，举个例子，对于丹刚才提到的那件事，每当人们在滑梯前坐下来才往下滑时，他们发现每个人会多花半秒钟。如果有大约 100 名乘客要从一个门出去，那就会耽误 40 或 50 秒。
But if you need to get everyone out in 90 seconds, then 50 seconds is more than you can afford. So I thought the jumping on the slide was a structural thing, but that's actually just a time thing? Yeah, I thought that too, that sitting down would like damage the slide. Yeah. No, it's all about getting the passengers out as quickly as possible. Oh, that is fascinating.
但如果你需要在 90 秒内让所有人都撤离，那么 50 秒就是你无法承受的时间。所以我以为在滑梯上坐一下是个结构上的问题，但实际上这只是个时间问题？对，我也曾这么想过，以为坐一下会损坏滑梯之类的。对。不，这一切全都是为了以最快的速度让乘客撤离。哦，这太迷人了。
Yeah, but one of the most important things Bowen Dan learned was that one of the best ways to get out of the airplane on time was, surprise, to read the safety card. Wow, they're important. They really are important when they had people read the safety cards and when those cards had the relevant information, the evacuation times improved dramatically. So they began applying what they learned in the experiments to the design and improved dramatically. So they began applying what they learned
对，但博和丹学到的最重要的事情之一就是：能够按时逃离飞机的最佳方法之一，居然是阅读安全卡。哇，它们真的很重要。它们确实非常重要。当他们让人们阅读安全卡，并且当这些卡片包含相关信息时，疏散时间显著缩短了。因此，他们开始将从实验中学到的知识应用到卡片的设计中，
in the experiments to the design and the cards. And we said, okay, how can we improve these? And then we said no words, just pictures. And then Bowen Dan would test the cards out on the public and see if people could understand the illustration. We'd say, we've got a second here, Mr. We've got something here we'd like for you to take a look at and tell us what you think.
并且显著提高了效率。我们说，好吧，我们该如何改进这些卡片呢？然后我们说不要文字，只要图片。接着，博和丹会把这些卡片拿给公众测试，看看人们能否理解插图。我们会说：“先生，我们借您一秒钟。我们这里有个东西想请您看一下，然后告诉我们您的想法。”
And we have to have 90% understandability or we're not going to sell this card. And the result was cards that look a lot like the cards you see today. They used pictures to tell the entire story of how to exit the plane. And they zoomed in on specific important actions like how to open a door. And there were also things that you might not consciously notice, but which apparently really help,
“并且我们需要达到 90% 的理解率，否则我们绝不发布这张卡片。”其结果就是，这些卡片看起来非常像你今天看到的卡片。他们用图片来讲述如何逃离飞机的整个故事。并且他们放大了特定的重要动作，比如如何开门。还有一些你可能不会有意识地注意到，但显然真的很有帮助的设计，
like using red for all the exit-related arrows, and pretty much having no text on the card, except for the word exit. Huh, yeah, I've never really thought about that, that exit is the only word. Yeah, they just contained all these visual strategies that nudge the reader towards comprehension. And as a final little design flourish, instead of like getting swallowed up by the seat back pocket, their cards actually fit, so the title would just peek out and sort of entice the passenger to open it up. And when they look down, all they could see was just in Intriguing, just in case, just in case what?
比如将所有与出口相关的箭头都用红色标出，并且卡片上几乎没有文字，除了“出口（exit）”这个词。哈，是的，我以前从来没有想过“exit”是唯一的文字。对，它们包含了所有这些能够引导读者理解的视觉策略。作为最后一个小小设计亮点，他们的卡片没有被座椅背后的口袋整个吞没，而是设计得刚好合适，这样标题就会稍微露出来，从而诱导乘客将其打开。当他们低头看时，他们能看到的只有“耐人寻味”、“以防万一”……以防万一什么？
This is the ABC evening news with Harry Reesner and Barbara Walters. Good evening. Yesterday the averages caught up with the 747. Two of them, both on charter flights, both on the ground, collided at Tenerife Airport in the Canary Islands. The Tenerife crash in March of 1977 is the moment where Boeing Dan's cards really were put to the test. Because it involved two large planes, it's still the single deadliest aviation accident in history. Why it happened is kind of up for debate, but basically a 747 belonging to KLM, an airline carrier, collided on take-off with
这里是哈里·里斯纳（Harry Reasoner）和芭芭拉·沃尔特斯（Barbara Walters）为您带来的 ABC 晚间新闻。大家晚上好。昨天，平均指数终于追上了波音 747。两架飞机，都是包机，都在地面上，在加那利群岛的特内里费机场（Tenerife Airport）发生了相撞。1977 年 3 月的特内里费空难，正是博和丹的安全卡真正接受终极考验的时刻。由于涉及两架大型飞机，它至今仍是历史上单起死伤最惨重的航空事故。事故原因众说纷纭，但基本上是一架属于荷兰皇家航空（KLM）的 747 在起飞时，与一架
a Pan Am 747 that was still on the runway. And the KLM plane tore the roof off of the Pan Am plane. Oh my god. Yeah and on the KLM plane everyone died and that easily could have been the case with the panamplain too. It got very hot inside the panamplain because of the fuel. Fuel leaking down from the KLM plane into the cabin. So at a certain point the conditions in the cabin became unsurvivable. But 67 people did survive. And it turned out that Dan and Bo designed the safety card for the Pan Am 747, meaning their card was the one on board the plane with the survivors.
仍在跑道上的泛美航空（Pan Am）747 发生了相撞。荷兰皇家航空的飞机削掉了泛美航空飞机的机顶。噢天哪。是的，荷航飞机上的所有人都遇难了，泛美航空的飞机本来也很可能遭遇同样的命运。由于燃油原因，泛美航空的机舱内变得非常热。燃油从荷航飞机泄漏并流进机舱。所以在某个时刻，机舱内的环境变得无法生存。但有 67 人幸存了下来。事实证明，丹和博正是那架泛美航空 747 安全卡的设计者，这意味着他们的卡片正是幸存者所乘坐的那架飞机上的那张。
And one of the at least that I talked to said that if it wasn't for the safety card, he and his wife would not have gotten out of the plane. Wow. That's amazing. Yeah. Apparently, this one couple, Paul and Floyd HECK somewhat famously escaped the crash while clutching a safety card in their hands. I actually have a copy of that safety card. Okay, so let me check this out. So it says 747, just in case, dot, dot, dot, and you open it up. And it's really like the modern card. You know, like, has opened up the door, jumping onto the slide, the layout of the plane. And it's, it is a quantum leap forward over the ones you showed me earlier that were all
据我交谈过的一位生还者说，如果不是因为那张安全卡，他和他的妻子根本无法逃出飞机。哇。这太惊人了。是的。显然，这对夫妇，保罗（Paul）和弗洛伊德·赫克（Floyd HECK），在手里紧紧攥着一张安全卡的情况下逃出了飞机，这在当时还算小有名气。我其实有一份那张安全卡的复制品。好的，让我来看看这个。所以上面写着“747，以防万一……”然后你把它打开。它真的很像现代的安全卡。你知道的，比如打开舱门、跳上滑梯、飞机的布局。而且，与你之前给我看的那些全都是
text, you know, and beautiful pictures, but really just, just impenetrable. Yeah, it, it seems like one that would save lives. Exactly. And they really saw the fact that there were survivors in Tenerife as kind of a vindication of their work. And after Tenerife, Bowen Dan actually testified before Congress about the need for better airline safety procedures. And it's around that time that the all-visual safety cards became the standard throughout the industry.
文字、虽然图片漂亮但实际上却完全晦涩难懂的卡片相比，它真是一个质的飞跃。是的，它看起来确实是那种能够救命的卡片。没错。他们确实将特内里费有生还者这一事实视为对其工作的某种平反和肯定。特内里费空难之后，博和丹甚至在国会作证，强调改进航空安全程序的必要性。正是在那个时候，全视觉的安全卡成为了整个行业的标准。
So, did they learn anything else from the trustee at Tenerife? Like, were the things that they discovered that they could have done better even? Yeah, that's a great question. Given that some of the survivors said the safety cards definitely helped them, why weren't there even more survivors? And they found that there are really two big hurdles preventing people from absorbing the information in the safety cards. The first is that when the crash happened, a lot of people just froze. Some of the survivors gave us some information on they were going down the ILA to get to an exit
那么，他们从特内里费的悲剧中学到了其他什么东西吗？比如，还有没有什么他们发现自己本可以做得更好的地方？是的，这是一个很好的问题。既然一些幸存者说安全卡确实帮了他们，为什么没有更多的生还者呢？他们发现，阻碍人们吸收安全卡中信息的其实有两个巨大的障碍。首先是，当坠机发生时，很多人直接吓呆了。一些幸存者向我们提供了一些信息，说他们当时正沿着过道走向出口，
and there were people sitting there with their mouth open. They didn't know what to do, they didn't know what to move, they didn't do anything, they just sat there and died. Investigators at Tenerife found that some of the victims were still buckled in their seats. Like they were so shocked, they couldn't even unbuckle their seatbelts. Yeah, it is pretty creepy, but it's also apparently common in plain crashes. It's called tonic immobility, and psychologists think that this is like a primitive defense mechanism, because one way to get a predator to leave you alone is just to play dead. And it turns out that this explains the thing that from the beginning I have found the most perplexing about the safety cards.
结果有些人呆坐在那里，嘴巴张得大大的。他们不知道该做什么，不知道该怎么移动，什么都不做，就那么坐在那里等死。特内里费的调查人员发现，一些遇难者甚至还把安全带系在座位上。就好像他们受到了极大的惊吓，连安全带都解不开了。是的，这确实让人毛骨悚然，但显然这也是空难中常见的情况。这被称为“强直性不动”（tonic immobility），心理学家认为这是一种原始的防御机制，因为让捕食者离开你的一种方法就是装死。事实证明，这就解释了我从一开始对安全卡感到最困惑的事情。
Why in the world of the safety card is everything so orderly and sort of panicless? I think that there's a fear of being in an airplane accident and anything that we do that might increase that fear would probably increase the incidence of tonic immobility. The placid faces, the perfectly quaffed hair. The very thing that Fight Club is making fun of, it turns out that that is not like a shallow corporate marketing decision. Dan says the bloodless design is at least partially about keeping passengers from panicking even more and maybe even freezing up.
为什么在这个世界上，安全卡里的所有东西都如此井然有序且毫无恐慌感呢？我认为人们对遭遇空难有着一种恐惧，而我们所做的任何可能会增加这种恐惧的事情，都可能会增加强直性不动发生的几率。平静的面孔，完美梳理的头发。正是《搏击俱乐部》所嘲讽的那种东西，事实证明，那可不是什么肤浅的企业营销决策。丹说，这种没有血腥味的设计至少有一部分是为了防止乘客陷入更深的恐慌，甚至可能导致大脑空白而呆若木鸡。
So you mentioned that there are two big hurdles. One is that the people freeze up before using the information on the cards. What's the second big hurdle when it comes to safety cards? The second hurdle is something that we talked about at the very beginning of the story, which is that nobody reads them. Nobody reads the cards. Besides you. Yeah, it turns out that the little Justin case teaser doesn't really work that well. You're going to get a lot of people, this is I am not going to do that. I don't want to read this. I don't want to look at it. I don't want to do anything at all about it. Period. I want to get to Dallas and I don't give a **** about anything else. I mean, period. I want to get to Dallas and I don't give a sh** about anything else.
所以你提到有两个巨大的障碍。一个是人们在使用卡片上的信息之前吓呆了。那关于安全卡的第二个巨大障碍是什么呢？第二个障碍正是我们在故事一开始时讨论过的内容，那就是根本没人看它们。根本没人看卡片。除了你之外。是的，事实证明那个小小的“以防万一”的预告并没有什么太大作用。你会遇到很多人，他们的态度是：我才不干呢。我不想读这个。我不想看它。我什么都不想做，绝对不。我只想去达拉斯，至于别的我他妈一点都不在乎。我的意思是，真的，我只想去达拉斯，至于别的我他妈一点都不在乎。
I mean, that's their attitude. Dan told me that even today, only 3 or 4% of passengers ever pick up the safety card. Is this why they now do safety videos, you know, not relying solely on the cards? Well, the videos help up to a point, but even the briefing videos have their limits. Like, they work really well with first-time flyers, but they still fall flat, just like the cards, when it comes to frequent flyers. So you get the cards, you get the videos, and also things like the flight demonstrations, but I wonder if there's any other way to reach the most resistant passengers.
我是说，这就是他们的态度。丹告诉我，即使在今天，也只有 3% 到 4% 的乘客会去拿安全卡看一看。这就是为什么他们现在制作安全视频的原因吗？你知道的，不再完全依赖卡片？嗯，视频在一定程度上有所帮助，但即使是安全演示视频也有其局限性。比如，它们对第一次坐飞机的乘客非常有效，但对于经常坐飞机的常客来说，视频就和卡片一样起不到什么作用。所以你有卡片，你有视频，还有诸如飞行安全演示之类的事情，但我很好奇是否还有其他方法能够触及那些最抵触的乘客。
Like, have they tried other things to inject the necessary information into people's brains? So there are some other methods that airline companies have tried to get passengers' attention and they haven't gone that well. Bo told me about this one carrier Eastern Airlines that tried an experiment. They had everybody to come into the facility 15 minutes early and then they had to go to this room and they got to pass passenger safety briefing in the room Then they went out of business Both as the cards the demonstrations the videos they all help get more information across to more people
比如，他们有没有尝试过其他方法把必要的信息塞进人们的脑子里？航空公司确实尝试过一些其他方法来吸引乘客的注意力，但效果并不是很好。博跟我讲过这么一家航空公司——东方航空（Eastern Airlines），他们曾尝试过一个实验。他们让所有人在飞机起飞前 15 分钟来到一个设施里，然后他们必须去这个房间，并在房间里通过乘客安全须知。然后他们就破产了。博说，无论是卡片、演示还是视频，它们都有助于将更多信息传达给更多人。
But in the end the information will always hit this wall of resistance among passengers We try to teach them. We try to encourage them. We do all those things, but people's attitudes stick, and you can't change that. You cannot change that. So you have to look at it and say, how many people can I trust to do what they're told to do? Probably 30%. 30%. But what do you do? You have to play the odds. That's all there is to it. So really, when it comes down to it, if I really want to survive a crash or some kind of
但最终，这些信息在乘客当中总是会撞上这堵抵触的高墙。我们试图教导他们。我们试图鼓励他们。我们做了所有这些事情，但人们的态度根深蒂固，你是无法改变这一点的。你无法改变这一点。所以你必须认清现实，然后问自己：我可以信任多少人去按照要求去做？大概 30%。30%。但你能怎么办呢？你只能押注于概率。这就是全部。所以归根结底，如果我真的想在空难或某种
problem on an airplane, the final step really rests with me. I have to watch the video. I have to read the card. Like, this is my responsibility is. The final step really rests with me. I have to watch the video. I have to read the card. Like, this is my responsibility is take that final step. Yeah, and oh my God, I'm just cringing. Like, I feel like at the risk of turning this whole story into a PSA, it really is the truth that we all have to actively participate in taking our own safety seriously.
飞机故障中幸存下来，最后一步其实还是取决于我自己。我必须看视频。我必须读卡片。这就是我的责任。最后一步其实取决于我自己。我必须看视频。我必须读卡片。这就是我的责任，去迈出最后这一步。是的，哦天哪，我简直感到尴尬得脚趾抠地。就像我觉得，冒着把整个故事变成公共服务广告（PSA）的风险，事实确实是我们所有人都必须积极参与，认真对待我们自己的安全。
And I still, I love the cards. I just see them a little bit differently now. Before doing all this reporting, to me, they were just like physical, laminated artifacts of people pretending to have control in a crisis. Like, they were enduring, because they were so futile, because they didn't matter. Yes, that's like the main reason that I took them from place. But now, and I know I'm gonna sound like I'm goody too to say this, but the next time I board a plane,
而且我依然爱着这些卡片。我只是现在对它们的看法有些不同了。在做所有这些报道之前，对我来说，它们只是人们在危机中假装自己能够掌控一切的实体层压制成品。它们之所以能流传下来，是因为它们如此徒劳，因为它们根本无关紧要。是的，这就像是我从飞机上顺走它们的主要原因。但现在——我知道说这话听起来我像个乖乖女——但下次我登上一架飞机时，
I'm gonna pull out the safety information card, and I'm gonna read it, note where the exits are, how to open the door, and then when I'm finished, I'm gonna put it back in the seat back pocket and hope that the next person reads it too. We come back, we'll talk to some of the people who actually draw safety cards for a living and find out why you really want them to do a good job after this. So we're back with safety card criminal, Mo the board. So Mo, I know that there was some stuff that we couldn't fit in the piece and you talked
我会把安全须知卡抽出来，认真阅读它，记下出口在哪里、怎么开门，然后当我看完之后，我会把它放回座椅背后的口袋里，并希望下一个乘客也能读一读它。我们回来后，将与一些真正以绘制安全卡为生的人聊聊，并找出为什么你真的希望他们能把工作做好。接下来是广告。欢迎回来，我是安全卡惯偷莫·勒博恩。所以莫，我知道有些内容我们没能塞进正片里，而且你除了博和丹之外，还和
to other people besides Bowen Dan. Yeah, when I was researching this story, one of the things I learned is that Bowen Dan had all these great innovations, but you know, neither of of them are artists, like they don't draw the cards. So I got really curious about who it is that does the drawing, like what actually goes into creating one of these things. So I called up Brock Fisher and Larry Bruns. When you tell people, this is what you do, what does most people say? Um, one I get a lot is that's a real job. Or that pays the bills.
其他人聊过。是的，在研究这个故事时，我了解到的一点是，博和丹虽然有所有这些伟大的创新，但你知道，他们俩都不是艺术家，他们不会画卡片。所以我开始对究竟是谁在画画感到非常好奇，比如创作这些东西到底需要付出什么。于是我给布洛克·费舍尔（Brock Fisher）和拉里·布伦斯（Larry Bruns）打了个电话。当你告诉别人这就是你的工作时，大多数人会说什么？嗯，我经常听到的一句是：“这也是份真正的工作啊。”或者“这能糊口吗？”
I get that one quite a bit. Most people don't say anything. So the first guy you heard is Brock and the second guy's Larry. Together they comprise Air Safety Art International. And, adorably, they are a grandfather, grandson, safety card design duo. Ha ha ha duo. Nice.
我经常听到这句话。大多数人什么都不说。所以你刚才听到的第一个人是布洛克，第二个人是拉里。他们合伙组成了国际航空安全艺术公司（Air Safety Art International）。而且，非常可爱的是，他们是一对祖孙安全卡设计搭档。哈哈，双人组。不错。
I love it. Yeah. And apparently, major airline companies have their own in-house design teams. But smaller airlines turn to companies like Brock and Larry's to make their safety cards. And they also do a lot of private jets and helicopters, which means that they have a lot of fancy clients, some of which they could tell me on the record and helicopters, which means that they have a lot of fancy clients, some of which they could tell me on the record and some of which they couldn't.
我太喜欢了。是的。显然，各大航空公司都有自己的内部设计团队。但小型航空公司则会求助于像布洛克和拉里这样的公司来制作他们的安全卡。他们还为很多私人飞机和直升机设计，这意味着他们有很多高端客户，其中一些客户他们可以向我透露，
Okay, yeah, I can tell you. I did Taylor Swift's Falcon jet. Really? Yeah, I don't know if it's the same one she has now, but I did want to Taylor Swift's briefing cards. Yes, I confess I was star struck. I was very impressed. But even more impressive is that Larry is the guy who
而另一些则不能。好吧，是的，我可以告诉你。我做过泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift）的猎鹰（Falcon）喷气式飞机。真的吗？是的，我不知道是不是她现在用的那一架，但我确实做过泰勒·斯威夫特的安全须知卡。是的，我承认我当时追星了。我印象非常深刻。但更令人印象深刻的是，拉里就是那个
did all the drawings for Bowen Dan's first visual cards back in the 60s. Turns out he's Bow's brother-in-law. So this is like a family family business. Totally, yes. Which means that Larry helped develop the classic safety card look. The retro clothes and the crisp clean lines and of course no words. Words in a briefed card just kill me and unfortunately they're out there. And for the past few years he's been teaching his grandson Brock all the secrets of safety card illustration. Oh so okay we have to hear some secrets of safety card illustrations. What are they? I mean what what goes into designing a safety card that maybe I am not noticing?
在 60 年代为博和丹的第一批视觉安全卡绘制所有插图的人。原来他是博的连襟。所以这就像是一个家族家族企业。完全是的。这意味着拉里帮助奠定了经典安全卡的外观。复古的服装、清晰干净的线条，当然还有——没有文字。说明卡片上的文字简直要了我的命，但不幸的是，它们现在到处都是。在过去的几年里，他一直在将安全卡插图的所有秘诀传授给他的孙子布洛克。哦，好吧，我们必须听听安全卡插图的一些秘诀。它们是什么？我是说，设计一张安全卡到底需要投入什么，可能是我没有注意到的？
Well, the big goal is that grasping the information presented in the card should feel effortless. So it's trying to make sure that it's a little story and that the whole story makes sense without someone going, whoa, wait a minute. And that little story is the story of how you get off the plane. And it starts with making sure you understand where you are in the cabin. That's one that kind of gets me when I'm on an airliner, is if I'm looking at the card and I look up, do I see the same thing? And then they need to make sure that each scene in the narrative has only like a few key
嗯，最大的目标是，理解卡片上呈现的信息应该感觉毫不费力。所以这需要确保它是一个小故事，并且整个故事在没有人发出“哇，等一下”的疑问的情况下就能讲得通。而那个小故事就是你如何离开飞机的故事。它始于确保你明白自己在客舱里的位置。有一点经常让我困惑，当我在客机上时，如果我看着卡片然后抬头看，我看到的是一样的东西吗？然后他们需要确保叙事中的每个场景只有几个核心
details that stand out. Things like, if in that aircraft that handle is bright red, we need to show it bright red, not a generic gray or black. It needs to be red, because if that's the only thing you remember, at least you know what you're looking for. So the premise is that I'm panicking. I just have this glowing red handle in my mind's eye from the card, and I'm just thinking red handle, red handle, and then when I see it, I'm like, success,
突出的细节。比如，如果在那架飞机上那个把手是亮红色的，我们就需要把它画成亮红色的，而不是泛泛的灰色或黑色。它必须是红色，因为如果那是你唯一记住的东西，至少你知道自己在找什么。所以前提是我正在恐慌。我脑海里只有卡片上那个发光的红色把手，我脑子里一直想着红把手、红把手，然后当我看到它时，我会想：成功了，
then next step. Exactly, yes. But even conveying that is a lot of work because all the details you see in the card have to exactly match what's actually in the aircraft. So the passengers don't get confused. So Larry and Brock told me that they need images or samples of all of the objects in each
接下来一步。没错，是的。但即使是传达这一点也需要大量的工作，因为你在卡片上看到的所有细节都必须与飞机上的实际情况完全匹配。这样乘客才不会感到困惑。所以拉里和布洛克告诉我，他们需要每个
carrier's version of each different plane. Right. Like, you would be shocked at how many different types of door handles there are. Or safety vests, there are. There are so many types of inflatable safety vests. Larry and Brock say they've drawn about 150 types of lifefests and rafts. I never really thought of that, but that's totally true. Yeah, it has to be exactly right, or it doesn't really do its job.
不同机型版本中所有物品的图片或样品。对。你会对门把手的种类繁多感到震惊。或者救生衣，有那么多。有太多种充气救生衣了。拉里和布洛克说他们大约画了 150 种救生衣和救生筏。我以前从来没想过这一点，但这绝对是真的。是的，它必须完全正确，否则它就无法真正发挥作用。
Yeah. And the same thing goes for all the different actions that the passengers are expected to perform. Because they need to accurately convey what each of those actions look like, but also feel like. When we draw people, we have them carry weight. Like we add muscle shape inside the lines. We kind of like show them bending and the creakles in the shirt. So it looks like he's heaving this raft.
是的。所有要求乘客执行的不同动作也是如此。因为他们需要准确传达每一个动作看起来是什么样的，同时也得传达出那种感觉。当我们画人物时，我们会让他们带上重量。比如我们在线条内部添加肌肉的形状。我们有点像是展示他们的弯曲以及衬衫上的褶皱。所以看起来他正在使劲拉动这个救生筏。
So we create the illusion of mass and weight really quickly. And that means that they've also ended up with a vast library of customized character poses. So in the end, we probably have, I don't know, we've never done the math. There's got to be a thousand different characters, and 985 of them are me, so. So.
因此我们非常迅速地创造了质量和重量的错觉。这意味着他们最终也拥有了一个庞大的定制角色姿势库。所以最后，我们大概有——我不知道，我们从来没算过。肯定有一千个不同的角色，其中 985 个都是我，所以。所以。
So. So. Yeah, this is the final safety card secret. Many of the characters you see in their cards, regardless of what they look like on the page, really, they're just, brock, like, they're just based on photos of him in a nice pair of slacks on a dress shirt. People actually like, why is that for that? They'll start to look and be like, it's just the same guy in every situation on this card.
所以。是的，这是最后一个安全卡秘诀。你在他们的卡片上看到的许多角色，不管他们在页面上看起来怎么样，说实话，他们其实只是——布洛克，就像是，他们只是根据他穿着一条漂亮的休闲裤和一件正装衬衫的照片画出来的。人们其实会——为什么会这样？他们会开始看然后说：“这卡片上每种情况下的怎么都是同一个家伙呀。”
That's so good. This is my favorite fun fact, because when Brock's body type won't do, they just recruit anybody. Like, they're cousin, they're spouse, they're friend, to come put on business casual, or like a flight attendant outfit and pose for the cards. We've for some reason, recruit waitresses from restaurants that we used to go to when we were in Bellingham. We asked them if they want to make an extra 100 bucks,
太棒了。这是我最喜欢的趣事，因为当布洛克的体型不合适时，他们就会随便招募任何人。比如，他们的表亲、配偶、朋友，来换上商务休闲装，或者像空姐一样的制服，为卡片摆出姿势。出于某种原因，我们会在贝灵厄姆（Bellingham）时常去的餐馆里招募女服务员。我们问她们想不想赚外快 100 块钱，
and they usually say yes. We were, really? It just come out of my house and pretend to be a crash card model. Yeah, and they actually asked me if I wanted to be a safety card model. Oh my god. Did you say yes? Yes, I was like... Of course. It is super niche and super cool. They haven't had an order come in where they need basically a woman to do a very specific action yet, but when they do, I'll be there. Oh, this has been so much fun. Thanks so much.
她们通常都会说好。我们当时就想，真的吗？就来我家，假装当一个空难卡片模特？是的，他们甚至问过我是否想当一个安全卡模特。天哪。你答应了吗？答应了，我当时的心情是……当然啦。这超级小众又超级酷。他们还没接到需要一个女性来做某个非常具体动作的订单，但当他们接到时，我就会出现。哦，这太有趣了。非常感谢。
Thank you, Roman. 99% invisible was produced this week by Mo the Bored, edited by Joe Rosenberg, mixed by Bryson Barnes, music by Sean Raell. Delaney Hall is the senior producer, Kurt Colstata is the digital director, the rest of the team is Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Chris Barube, Vivian Le, Katie Mingle, Abby Medon, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to the Johan Pill, who we spoke to for this story about the history of safety card design, but whose voice we didn't get to include.
谢谢你，罗曼。本周的 99% Invisible 由莫·勒博恩制作，乔·罗斯伯格（Joe Rosenberg）剪辑，布赖森·巴恩斯（Bryson Barnes）混音，肖恩·拉埃尔（Sean Raell）配乐。德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯塔塔（Kurt Kolstata）是数字总监，团队的其他成员包括克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）、维维安·勒（Vivian Le）、凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、艾比·梅登（Abby Medon）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢约翰·皮尔（Johan Pill），我们为这个关于安全卡设计历史的故事采访了他，但很遗憾没能将他的声音收录其中。
Some of the images Mo and I looked at are actually from an incredible book he put together with co-author Eric Erickson. It's called Design for Impact, and it contains images of safety cards from different periods all over the world is absolutely gorgeous book and it's just so much fun to flip through. If you want to check it out, we'll have a link on our website, 99pi.org. We are a project of K-AIL W-91.7 in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row, which lives at the far corners of North America, but is centered in beautiful downtown,
我和莫看的一些图片其实来自于他与合著者埃里克·埃里克森（Eric Erickson）共同编著的一本精彩绝伦的书。它叫做《设计的冲击》（Design for Impact），里面包含了世界各地不同时期的安全卡图片，绝对是一本华丽至极的书，翻阅起来趣味无穷。如果你想了解一下，我们会在我们的网站 99pi.org 上放一个链接。我们是旧金山 K-AIL W-91.7 的一个项目，制作于广播街（Radio Row），它位于北美洲的偏远角落，但以美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心为核心。
Oakland, California We're a founding member of radio topia from pierrex a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative listener supported 100% artist-owned podcasts in the world Find them all at radio topia.fm You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI or we're on Instagram and read it too. You can now order our first book, the 99% Invisible City at 99PI.org's Flash Book. We have links to purchase that anywhere you get your books including Signed Editions and the Audio Book and if you did get a book and enjoyed it. Review it somewhere.
我们是 Radiotopia from PRX 的创始成员，这是一个由世界上最具创新性、听众支持、100% 艺术家拥有的独立播客集体组成的充满激烈的独立阵营。你可以在 radiotopia.fm 上找到所有这些播客。你可以在 Twitter 上 @Roman Mars，或者在节目账号 @99PI 找到我，我们在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上也有账号。你现在可以订购我们的第一本书《99% Invisible City》，网址是 99pi.org 的 Flash Book 页面。我们在那里提供了购买该书的各种链接，无论你在哪里买书都能买到，包括签名版和有声书。如果你买了一本书并且很喜欢它，请在某个地方写个评价。
It's a huge help to us when you review it in lots of different places. For all your other 99PI needs, look no further than 99ipi.org. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你在很多不同的地方给我们写评价，这对我们有巨大的帮助。有关99PI的所有其他需求，请访问99ipi.org。来自PRX。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。